yeah i think well it's not something i
think it's
so
that the body
is an incredibly
sensitive
and delicate instrument
for interacting with the world
for instance
an example that i like to use some of
you may remember from when you were
children if you got a really good
chemistry set
there would be a thing in it called a
spinthoroscope
do you all know what a spinthoroscope is
you could make one of these they're
really neat you could make one this
seems to be the metaphor of the morning
you could make one with the paper tube
from the inside of a roll of toilet
paper
what a spenthoros scope is is it's a
it's a little pipe
usually no longer than this and in one
end it has a lens
and in the other end it has a painted
phosphorus screen like a television set
but just a little piece of cardboard
that's got a some phosphorus painted on
it and right in front of the phosphorus
screen
is a needle
which has been dipped in airplane glue
and then the end of the needle has been
rolled in the kind of radium that is on
a glow-in-the-dark watch
you know
so what you do with the spinthoroscope
is you go into a closet
and close the door and you sit in
darkness for about 10 minutes
and then you look into the
spinthoroscope
and lo and behold
it looks like
twinkling stars
you see little flashes of light
randomly on the other end of the
spinthoroscope these are
get this
single photons
of light
because the radiation from the radium is
striking the phosphorus screen
and kicking out single photons
from uh from the phosphorus
this is
you you sitting here 145 pounds of meat
are looking right at single photons
coming into existence you're looking
into the quantum realm
now they've also done experiments where
in a special kind of apparatus they can
uh
i don't know how they keep the eardrum
from bursting but they they evacuate air
from the ear and then they can release a
single
oxygen molecule
into the ear and you can actually hear
it
bumping against the tympanic membrane
well so these kinds of experiments are
by way of example
that the human body is an instrument
with a range of ability that reaches
from the quantum mechanical foundations
of matter up to
when you look through a large telescope
out into the galaxy you know you can
physically have light fall on your eyes
that has been traveling for four or five
billion years so the human body is an
incredibly advanced instrument for the
exploration of nature and we have you
know we think you can't learn anything
about quantum physics unless you build
an instrument 17 kilometers in diameter
that costs 100 billion dollars and
provides pork barrel for 20 years for a
bunch of weasel politicians this is just
because of our obsession with
instrumentality
but what the shaman knows is that the
human body is a superb instrument for
for doing this kind of thing
that's why i take i think the models of
reality that emerge out of shamanism are
equally on a par with
the crowd that's seeking the
you know
the top quark and all that other stuff i
mean these things are pretty airy fairy
stuff
and usually
the argument for them rests on the fiat
of some fishy formula
so
part of the whole thing about
psychedelics i think is and i hammer on
this all the time
is what i call reclaiming the felt
presence of immediate experience
this is what
you are
you are not
time magazine or national public radio
or any of this stuff the felt presence
of immediate experience here
now
everything else is
rumor innuendo
illusion
factual ricochet
and and uh we as a culture have
completely sold ourselves out i mean we
all run around with the idea
little me
what do i know the guys at sri
they know the guys at nimh notice guys
guys everywhere
this is a kind of self
definition that is totally disempowering
and shamans
all they trust is their own experience
and they don't even trust their memories
of their own past experience the world
is made new
each time so the felt presence of
experience is all you'll ever know it's
all you ever can know so why not empower
it
[Music]
you